For the experts in emotion interview.
We'll have the honor.
Speaking with Doctor Jessica Tracy.
I'm doctor Tracy is an associate professor of psychology at the University of
British Columbia in Vancouver,
Canada,
where she's also a Michael Smith Foundation for health research scholar and a
Canadian Institute for health research new investigator.
She received her phd from the University of California Davis in 2005.
Doctor Tracy's research focuses on emotions and emotion expressions and in
particular on the self conscious emotions of pride,
shame and guilt.
Dr Tracy's research has been covered by numerous media outlets,
including ABC's Good Morning America and prs,
all things considered the New York Times,
the Los Angeles Times,
the Boston Globe,
the economist,
the New Scientist,
and scientific American among many others.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Jessica Tracy.
So welcome Jess.
Thanks for speaking today.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
So I thought what we could do is start off a little bit by asking you about what
first got you interested in emotion in the first place.
Sure,
yeah.
Um,
so I started Grad school in the late nineties,
early two thousands,
and at that time,
emotion was sort of the hot topic.
I think it's still pretty hot,
but at that time it was the new thing that kind of everyone was studying.
And I learned that,
you know,
kind of upon entering Grad school.
And it was great because emotion,
something that I've sort of had this kind of intrinsic interest in.
And I think that's for a couple of reasons.
One is that I've always kind of been most interested in basic level processes,
things that sort of go on in the mind,
the direct everything else.
Um,
I think my,
my sort of orientation has always been,
you know,
how could I study something complex like relationships or group behavior without
first knowing what's going on within one person's mind.
It's guiding all that.
And I'm amazed by people who do work on that stuff.
Cause I,
you know,
that's sort of my,
that's the way I understand things.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I think emotions are so essential.
They shaped so much of what we do and what we want and how we think and behave.
And at the time,
you know,
at the time I got into studying them,
I feel like there was actually sort of a perfect amount of scientific
understanding.
There'd been all this great work done by people that Pollock men and uh,
Richard Lazarus and Bob Levinson and,
and you know,
at that point we knew emotions were biological and they could be studied through
the scientific method,
but there was still also a great deal of mystery.
And I think there still is.
And to me that's always made them sort of this really fascinating topic of
inquiry.
So very cool.
So I won't ask you some questions about your own research where you've really
been a pioneer in this domain of self conscious emotions.
So,
I mean,
like I'm saying you've just connected some of the most influential work in this
domain and as an expert in self conscious emotions,
I wanted to just sort of pick your brain and ask you sort of what do you see as
the most important or you know,
unique features of self conscious emotions?
Yeah,
so I would say subconscious motions,
the way that I've always defined them and I think this is consistent with
definitions that are out there.
The way they,
the reason that they differ from other emotions is because of the south.
And that sort of goes with the name.
But the idea is that to feel as self conscious emotion you have to make a self
evaluation,
which means you have to use for the ice self,
the self that's the reflector and actually reflect on the self,
which is sort of yourself representations,
your identity,
your self concept.
Um,
and once you start doing that,
you know,
you make a self evaluation essentially.
You sort of think,
well,
how does the,
I feel about the me?
Do I feel good about myself that I just do a good thing or a bad thing?
And that results in emotions like shame,
guilt,
pride,
embarrassment and so on.
And you know,
I think that's a very unique feature.
These emotions,
other emotions like anger,
fear,
sadness,
absolutely can involve self evaluations,
but they don't have to,
that you can experience fear without thinking about yourself at all.
Whereas for these emotions you have to,
and I think that makes them unique and it also makes them,
I didn't really interesting,
especially as a social personality psychologist cause they're kind of
intricately interwoven with some of the processes that we all care most about.
Right.
Things like self esteem,
narcissism,
self concept formation,
self awareness,
um,
all kinds of interesting stuff that,
I think lots of self or self researchers for sure.
But social researcher.
So I've always been interested in so,
so what do you think are some of the most important next steps then?
Is this field of self conscious emotions kind of,
you know,
charts ahead,
forward.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I think there's been a good body of evidence building suggesting that at least
too self conscious emotions,
pride and shame are biological,
uh,
universal,
probably a Nate,
um,
this means that they're likely to be adaptations.
And this is kind of how I study stuff is sort of very evolutionary perspective.
And so from that angle,
you know,
I think one big question is,
um,
you know,
to what extent are these emotions sort of as core or basic as an emotion,
like anger or fear?
And to some,
to some extent this is sort of a semantic issue.
Um,
you know,
some things are innate and evolve.
It's an eight and above.
It doesn't really matter how core basic it is,
whatever that means.
Let me look again.
I think that neuroscience can be really useful in terms of figuring out what's
different in the brain when you experience something like pride versus
happiness.
There's gotta be a difference,
right?
Otherwise they wouldn't be different emotions.
So what is that difference and how does that help us understand the difference
between these two emotions?
Um,
I think cross species where it could also be really useful.
What other animals do we see these kinds of emotions in?
What did the evolutionary precursors,
and then I think in a whole other direction,
social,
uh,
social effects of these emotions,
right?
There's been a lot of work on the social impact of various emotions and,
and growing body of work on the social impact of pride and shame and guilt.
And I think that's where,
you know,
much more is needed because I think these are some of the most important
emotions that we have in terms of shaping social behavior,
right?
How we are in our relationships,
how we are as groups.
Um,
and they have huge effects on things like,
you know,
prejudice,
war,
patriotism,
all kinds of stuff.
And so I think that that's a really kind of exciting direction for staff.
So,
I mean,
in this realm,
what's really exciting is some of the work you've done,
right?
So you've conducted this,
you know,
someone will work sort of systematically describing and empirically documenting
the nature of pride.
Right?
And I wonder for those of us,
we all have,
may have some sort of intuition of what pride is,
but you,
what are the core features
of pride really,
you know,
from the scientific perspective that you've taken for the first time?
Yeah,
no,
thanks.
Um,
so yeah,
so when I started getting pride,
we kind of built on definitions that were out there largely from appraisal
theorist,
people like Richard Lazarus who said,
well,
pride is the emotion you experience when you've done something you feel good
about or you are someone that you feel good about,
right?
Basically it's a positive self evaluation.
And so taking it from that,
we kind of did a bunch of research to find,
well first of all,
actually there's two different ways of feeling pride,
right?
There's what we call authentic pride,
which is feeling good about something you did right?
And then there's hubristic pride,
which is more feeling good about who you are as a person.
It's a little bit more arrogant,
a little bit more global and stable.
Um,
and it turns out that these two kinds of pride are really different,
both in terms of how they feel,
but also in terms of what kinds of social effects they have rights.
They lead to different behaviors.
When you feel hubristic pride,
you actually become less empathic toward others.
And you might even feel prejudice against people who are different from
authentic pride actually promotes all kinds of pro social behaviors.
And they had divergent personality correlates as well.
So people who tend to feel authentic pride are agreeable and conscientious and
high achieving versus people who tend to feel hubristic pride are much more
aggressive,
a disagreeable intolerant,
that sort of thing.
So it's really kind of interesting distinction.
Um,
and then I guess the other kind of main finding I've,
I've done is that their pride is expressed through,
you know,
it's distinct nonverbal signal,
which is reliable,
recognized as displayed by people all over the world.
So yeah,
I was going to ask,
to what extent do you think pride really is this,
you know,
cultural,
universal emotion?
You know what I mean?
The data would suggest it is.
I think,
you know,
we,
we've done studies where we went to Burkina Faso,
which is west Africa,
and found that the people who live in a teeny little tribe there in the middle
of nowhere,
they almost never seen a white person.
You showed them photos of the pride expression and they recognize it and they
recognize it as well as they recognize pretty other every other,
pretty much every other emotion that we showed them,
which to me is fairly convincing.
Yeah.
Um,
we've also found that people all over the world spontaneously displayed this
expression.
I'm like doing it now.
Your success,
it's hard.
It's hard to talk about it and not do it.
But
so people all over the world spontaneously show it.
And that even holds for people who are congenitally blind.
So these are people who never seen anyone show the pride expression.
And yet after they've had a success,
that's exactly what they do.
And it's hard to come up with an explanation of why these people are,
how they would have come to learn about it if it wasn't sort of an innate
universal phenomenon.
So fascinating.
I mean,
I know you've also done some work.
I wonder if you could say a little bit about how to displace of pride even
influence things,
you know,
as a sort of,
socially gigantic in terms of influencing social power or status.
How can that display,
you know,
do just that,
right?
Yeah,
right.
Well let's certainly,
that's an idea that's been around for a long time.
I think,
you know,
as early as people began thinking about pride and psychology,
which isn't actually that early,
um,
they sort of talked about it as a high power emotion or status emotion and,
and work that I've done with [inaudible] Sharif.
What we've found is that when people show the pride expression,
other people on seeing it have this automatic really unavoidable tendency to
assume that the person showing it deserves high status and this tendency to see
the pride expression as high status.
Do you need to pry be compared probably with lots of other emotions including
things like happiness and anger,
which are also pretty powerful.
Emotions,
pride RB to them.
And then we found that even if people know that the person showing pride doesn't
deserve high status.
So for example,
we had a homeless person showing pride.
This is sort of the lowest status segment of society.
And we had a businessperson and it turns out that when the homeless person shows
pride,
he and his case was he,
he is perceived to be as high status as a business person who shows chain,
which is the low status motion.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I mean it really shows the piece emotions have these incredibly strong
effects that can overwhelm sort of rational judgment that we based on contextual
cues.
And we found that the effect of pride on status,
perceptions generalize across cultures as well.
So for this one we went to Fiji,
another sort of highly isolated small scale society in Fiji.
It's very isolated.
And we did this automaticity study where we had laptops,
which these people had never used and we measured the reaction times and sure
enough,
they also associated the pride expression with high status very reliably.
Oh Wow.
That's fascinating.
It was like,
and just,
I love how you're conducting your work.
Just all around the world too.
Cause I think so much of understanding and motion is understanding the different
potential cultural influences or to what extent your findings are robust to
culture.
Right?
And that they're universal.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I,
you know,
I mean I have sort of more taken a universalist sort of perspective,
but I think there's lots of stuff that's influenced by culture.
Self conscious emotions are absolutely influenced by culture and you know,
that's incredibly important too.
So it's important to you.
I wanted to ask about one other really important demand of work you've done that
I've been reading about.
I know a lot of other people have that's just got really important behavioral
health,
you know,
consequences.
So you've been looking at to what extent self conscious emotions like shame can
actually predict things like relapse or worsening among alcoholics in terms of
severity.
I wonder if you could say a little bit more about this.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
I'm glad you asked about that.
That's a really new study that we have that I'm super excited about.
Um,
yeah.
So what I did keep his project was,
um,
we kind of had,
I'd been studying shame for awhile and you know,
you get,
you get people who are undergrads to write about their shame experiences,
they're good.
You know,
so you get stories like,
oh,
I broke up with my girlfriend,
I felt really bad.
I forgot to call my mom.
It's good shame.
It's not sort of real intense shame.
And so thinking about this,
I thought,
well,
you know,
people who are coming from addiction addiction is so linked to shame as a
clinical psychologist,
I'm sure you know that.
And the kind of shame experiences that people who are recovering from alcoholism
have.
I'm just almost in a different realm from the undergrads that we are looking at.
So what we did was we did this study where we had alcoholics recovering
alcoholics come into the lab and talk about the last time they drank and felt
badly about themselves for it.
So it's sort of a shame induction procedure,
but it's almost getting it shame specifically about their addiction.
And the theory behind this is,
um,
you know,
a lot of people,
especially policymakers,
and there's a number of judges out there who sort of said,
well,
if you did something wrong,
you should feel shame about it.
And in fact,
that's exactly how you stopped doing that wrong thing.
You feel badly about it and then you fix,
you fix it.
And while that may be true for guilt and June Tangney has done a lot of work
showing that guilt has all these positive effects in the moral domain for shame.
It's,
it's less clear that that's the case because when you feel shame,
you sort of feel like this bad person.
And how did they make you want to fix things?
It makes you want to hide and run away.
And drinking alcohol for an addict is a great way of running away.
It's a really good escape.
And so our predictions were that will actually,
if you feel shame about your addiction from alcohol or your addiction to
alcohol,
it's not going to make you stop drinking.
It's actually going to have the reverse effect and make you kind of feel like
you need to escape that shame perhaps by drinking more.
Yeah.
So what we did was we had these alcoholics coming to the lab,
they've been sober about three months,
so newly sober and the relapse rate for people who've been sober about three
months is incredibly high overall.
Um,
it's just that sort of how it works.
and the human allowed me to talk about the last time they drank and felt bad
about it and we,
we,
we videotaped them all.
They did that and then we measured their nonverbal behaviors.
And the great thing about shame is you can actually measure it from people's
behaviors.
It's associated with things like a head tilt down,
shoulders slump,
chest narrow.
Yeah,
exactly right.
So we had a team of coders rate the extent to which they showed shame.
We then had everyone will come back about four months later.
It varied,
but on average it was four months later.
And when they came back,
we measured their health and we measured their health the first time to with
your questionnaires.
And we also asked them about whether they had drank since the last visit.
Now we didn't say,
did you drink since?
Since the last visit?
Because that's sort of a question.
It's a little bit almost biased.
Instead we just asked one of the last time you drank and you figured it out from
that.
And we also asked,
how many drinks did you have over the past three months?
I mean,
we give them a calendar and they had to fill it when people are generally pretty
good at remembering this kind of thing and you give him a calendar.
Um,
what we found was that the extent to which they showed shame and their bodies at
that first session strongly predicted whether they had relapsed when they came
back three months later,
four months later.
And for those who did relapse,
the,
the extent of shame that they showed predicted how many drinks they had.
In other words,
how bad the relapse was.
And that's even getting rid of the people who did relapse at all.
So it's not driven by that.
And they also have worst health.
Um,
so,
so it's really consistent with what we expected that in fact shame seems to be a
predictor for relapse.
And we controlled for all kinds of other variables that might be sort of third
factor stuff that could contribute to both like depression and low self esteem.
None of that was was accounting for this.
It's really the shame behaviors we think that are driving this effect.
That's fascinating.
With such important translational health outcomes too that you can link from the
basic science worlds who you know,
the mental health world.
Yeah,
no I would love that.
You know,
I'm not in clinical scientist,
but I love the idea that I'm actually doing something that could help people.
That's not something I've done in the past.
So it's exciting.
So I mean you've really done just this beautiful body of work from like just
really bringing the,
the field of self conscious of emotions to life,
looking at pride and then this recent work on shame and leaking it to
alcoholism.
And as you think about sort of where the field was,
when you started,
where you've come,
you know,
during that time,
if you look ahead sort of,
where do you see the future of this field going?
You have to get questioned.
You know what I mean?
I think the easiest answer to that is more neuroscience.
But you know,
the reason it's the easy answer is because that's been the answer since I got
into the field.
And in fact when I got into the field,
I was told if you're going to study emotions you're going to have to do
neuroscience.
And you know,
I have no problem with neuroscience.
It's just never been my thing.
And so far I haven't gotten into it.
I'm getting more into it sort of physiological stuff.
I've done some research cortisol.
Um,
but you know,
I haven't gotten into the hardcore neuroscience stuff and I think,
you know,
it,
I do want to point out that you can do really important emotion work just by
looking at behavior.
I think,
you know,
behaviors incredibly important window into this stuff and,
and that will never change.
So,
um,
so there is that.
Um,
and you know,
I think what I would say is,
I guess,
I don't know if this is the actual future,
but maybe my hope for the future is,
um,
I'd like to see more sort of ecologically valid work,
maybe more field work.
I think that,
you know,
like all,
um,
certainly all social psychology,
but maybe all social and cognitive and a broad range of fields,
aspect of science has been really kind of taking place in the lab,
right?
It's so experimental.
And then some point important and emotions are something that I think are great
to study with experiments because we can manipulate them for the most part.
But I think that what goes on in the lab is really different than what goes on
in the real world.
And I think we really need more studies going on in the real world,
measuring actual emotions that occur out there with different populations,
not just on the grads,
you know,
basically studying people in their natural habitat.
So I guess my hope for the future,
it's a good hope for the future.
And so when you have students come to you and ask you for advice who are
thinking about embarking in this field,
what do you tell them?
Um,
I guess,
you know what I would say is the thing you could start by doing is reading.
Um,
I think that's the most important thing.
You know,
when I,
when I started Grad School in 1999,
the first thing I did when I wanted to study emotions was I read this big book
that came out in 1995 by Ekman and Richie Davidson.
That was this questions.
But you probably know this book.
Yeah.
And it,
so they have like kind of 10 or 12 questions about emotions and then they had
all the leading emotion researchers give their little answer to the questions.
It's totally out of date now.
But it was great because,
you know,
he told me,
okay,
here are the major issues,
right?
The questions and here's what each thinker thinks and hear the debates.
And I just felt like I learned so much about the field from reading that book.
I don't think they've,
they've done a new additional where they should,
but um,
you know,
the handbook of aspect of science,
handbook of emotions,
all those kinds of things.
I think you're,
you're going to get the leading experts telling you what the big issues are and
what their opinion on those issues are.
And,
and that's,
I think the way to start.
You've got to know what we know before.
You can kind of move on from that.
And then,
you know,
read,
read journals,
read the journal emotion,
right.
I think it's a great journal.
It's a really good resource.
And um,
you know,
if you're,
if you're interested in this is what you want to study,
you should be reading at least the titles and maybe abstracts of every issue,
you know,
to know what's going on in there and then the articles for the ones that you're
actually interested in.
So reading,
I would say that's,
that's the way to start reading.
Excellent.
Well,
I want to say thanks for speaking today,
just,
it's been really,
really awesome talking to you.
No problem.
Happy to do it.
Yeah.
So this concludes our experts in emission interview with Doctor Jessica Tracy
from the University of British Columbia and Vancouver.
Thanks again.